[Music]
this time
oh no rules no punishments no more
secrets oh we've got secrets all right
plenty of them 50 shades darker is all
about these two gorgeous stars taking
their romance to the next level but it's
not just about what they do it's where
they do it
anybody's looking at us not us yeah for
this lavish masquerade ball scene they
didn't build a set they shot in this
real multi-million dollar Canadian
mansion from behind nearly 21,000 square
foot house has a curved staircase and
luxury living room but it might be
tricky shooting here in the future the
location will soon be converted into a
luxury retirement home but Taylor Swift
did not make the music video for the
movie song at the mansion it was shot at
a hotel in London I look so good the
story is set in Seattle but was actually
filmed in Vancouver Canada
welcome to the permanent a luxury event
space in the heart of downtown Vancouver
also home to Christian Grey is bang on
the last day of filming that Bank
building was robbed someone came in off
the street cut a hole through the fence
it took computers laptops and a whole
bunch of other keys to access other
rooms the case is still unsolved
we were really thankful that no one from
the film and none of our staff were here
when the robbery took place filming was
so top-secret they used an alias title
max and banks here it is printed on the
rap party's invitation
the party was held on the rooftop at the
Fairmont Hotel Vancouver and you might
recognize its wood paneled elevator from
the first movie we do actually have a
lot of fans coming by the hotel to a see
where it was filmed check please
[Music]
you